[Musique]
à quelle époque remonte la toute
première sert à l'époque de l'empiré
romain au premier siècle de notre ère
les médecins de l'empereur tibère lui
aurait conseillé de manger une variété
de melon non sucré chaque jour même en
hiver on l'avait donc conçu des lits de
culture rouleurs on sortait les plantes
quand il faisait beau et par temps froid
on les mettait à l'abri du vent sous une
structure faite de pierres translucide
et l'idée de faire pousser des fruits et
légumes à l'année ne s'arrête pas là
encore est un traité d'agriculture
datant du xvème siècle décrit la toute
première serre chauffée un ingénieux
système de plancher chauffant permettait
d'amener des légumes à maturité même
pendant la saison froide
propulsé par l'intérêt pour les plantes
exotiques la mode des serres gagne
l'europe ou xviie et xviiie siècles
touche à tout qui se respecte a
désormais son orangerie grande pièce
lumineuse chauffer en hiver où l'on
pouvait faire rentrer les orangers et
autres arbres fruitiers pour les
protéger du froid celle du château de
versailles pouvait en accueillir plus de
1000 le développement de l'industrie du
verre et les progrès de la métallurgie
permettront de créer au 19e siècle
dessert toujours plus grande ou
structures audacieuse et même si les
cerfs se sont aujourd'hui démocratiser
et servent à produire des fruits et
légumes ou quotidien le contrôle de la
température demeure encore et toujours
un enjeu